Hisamitsu.
>> L.A. UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT,
AS WELL AS SAN DIEGO SAN DIEGO,
ANNOUNCED THAT THEY ARE GOING TO
ENTER INTO THE FALL SCHOOL
SEASON THE WAY THEY ENDED LAST
SCHOOL YEAR.
THAT IS BY UTILIZING DISTANCE
LEARNING.
I WANT TO JUST ACKNOWLEDGE AND
APPLAUD THE LEADERSHIP OF THOSE
DISTRICTS.
>> Harris: THAT’S CALIFORNIA’S
DEMOCRATIC GOVERNOR,
GAVIN NEWSOM, PRAISING HIS
STATE’S TWO LARGEST SCHOOL
DISTRICTS, LOS ANGELES AND
SAN DIEGO.
THAT PRAISE COMING AFTER THEY
ANNOUNCED THEY WILL BEGIN THE
SCHOOL YEAR ON LINE AS
CORONAVIRUS CASES HAVE SPIKED
AGAIN IN THE GOLDEN STATE.
THE DECISION IS AFFECTING MORE
THAN 800,000 STUDENTS, AND IT
COMES AS OTHER STATES TAKE
DIFFERENT PATHS TO CLASSES
RESUMING WITH SOME PLANNING
HYBRID OPTIONS.
SOME PARTS AT HOME, SOME PARTS
DIGITAL LEARNING, THEY WILL DO A
MIX DURING THE WEEK IN SOME
PLACES.
BUT THE CONSERVATIVE-LEANING
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF EDUCATION
VOTED YESTERDAY TO REOPEN
SCHOOLS IN TIME FOR FALL
CLASSES, FOR IN PERSON LEARNING.
IT SAYS IT WILL NOT REQUIRE
SOCIAL DISTANCING OR WEARING A
MASK.
THEY SAY, "AMONG OUR GREATEST
RESPONSIBILITIES AS ADULTS IS
OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO MODEL
COURAGE AND PERSISTENCE IN THE
FACE OF UNCERTAINTY AND FEAR,
WHICH IS WHAT MANY FAMILIES ARE
FEELING WITH THE MIXED MESSAGES
AND CONFUSION SURROUNDING
REOPENING SCHOOLS IN THE
COVID-19 ERA."
JOINING ME NOW, WHITE HOUSE
PRESS
SECRETARY KAYLEIGH McENANY.
KAYLEIGH, GREAT TO HAVE IN THE
PROGRAM TODAY.
>> Secretary McEnany: GOOD TO
BE HERE.
>> Harris: I WANT TO START
THERE.
SOME OF THE CONCERN IS THAT THE
SCIENCE SPEAKS FOR ITSELF.
WE ARE LEARNING A LOT, WE EVEN
SAW THE PRESIDENT IN A MASK OVER
THE WEEKEND.
WE ARE LEARNING A LOT AS WE MOVE
FORWARD.
SOME PEOPLE WEAR A HEAD, SOME
PEOPLE ARE CATCHING UP, WHATEVER
THE PICTURE LOOKS LIKE.
IN A SCHOOL SETTING, IT ISN’T
JUST ABOUT THE KIDS.
IT’S ABOUT THOSE OLDER
EDUCATORS, ALSO SUPERIOR THOSE
KIDS GOING UP THEIR
GRANDPARENTS, PARTICULARLY IN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR, BECAUSE
YOU’RE NOT HIRING A NANNY.
YOU ARE DEPENDING ON YOUR AUNTS
AND UNCLES AND GRANDPARENTS.
AND MAYBE SPREADING EACH OF
THEM.
THE KIDS MIGHT NOT GET SICK, BUT
WE DON’T KNOW ENOUGH.
DR. BIRX SAYS WE ARE NOT TESTING
AND OF THEM TO KNOW IF THEY ARE
A SYMPTOMATIC CARRIERS.
UNDER THE AGE OF TEN.
WE JUST AREN’T.
>> Secretary McEnany: LET ME
POINT OUT A FEW THINGS, HARRIS.
ONE, THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
CLEAR HE SAYS VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS AMONG OUR TEACHERS
SHOULD STAY HOME.
THAT BEING SAID, DR. REDFIELD
HAS SAID ON THE RECORD THAT HE
IS THE HEAD OF THE CDC AND IT
HAS LITTLE EFFECT ON KIDS.
AN ANALYSIS THAT MANY IN THE
ACADEMIC COMMUNITY AGREE WITH.
HE SAID NOT ONLY THAT BUT THEY
ARE NOT DRIVING THE TRANSMISSION
CYCLE.
THERE WAS A STUDY AT SCHOOLS IN
NORTHERN FRANCE THAT FOUND THAT,
DESPITE COVID BEING IN THREE
SCHOOLS, THERE WAS NO
TRANSMISSION CYCLE THAT WAS
DRIVEN.
THE SCHOOLS WERE ABLE TO SAFELY
REOPEN, EVEN IN THIS COVID ERA.
WE KNOW THAT, IN CALIFORNIA
ALONE, THERE HAS NOT BEEN A
SINGLE DEATH UNDER THE AGE OF
18.
KIDS ARE NOT AFFECTED IN THE
SAME WAY AS THE VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS WHICH SHOULD STAY
HOME.
>> Harris: I HEAR YOU ABOUT
FRANCE, THEY DON’T HAVE THE
NUMBERS.
CERTAINLY NOT HR 25,000
KIDS IN THE SCHOOL DISTRICT OR
CROSS TO SCHOOL DISTRICT.
I HEAR YOU ABOUT PARTICULARLY
PUTTING THESE KIDS IN PERIL, THE
NUMBERS DON’T SUPPORT THAT THEY
WOULD NECESSARILY BE THE
CARRYING PART.
WE CAN AGREE TO DISAGREE UNTIL
THERE’S MORE SCIENCE.
BUT WHO IS THE PRESIDENT TALKING
TO AND LISTENING TO IN TERMS OF
PARENTS?
I WANT TO POP THIS UP.
71% OF U.S. PARENTS POLLED IN
THE NEW AXIOS’ EPISODES
CORONAVIRUS INDEX
SAY THAT IT WOULD BE RISKY TO
SEND CHILDREN BACK TO SCHOOL IN
THE FALL, INCLUDING NINE IN TEN
BLACK AMERICANS, AND EVEN
A SLIM MAJORITY OF REPUBLICANS.
THAT POLLING PARTICULARLY POPS
WHEN YOU AGAIN CONSIDER THAT, IN
THOSE AREAS, THAT’S WHERE
COVID-19 HAS DECIMATED SO MANY
PEOPLE AMONG ALL AGES.
>> Secretary McEnany: FIRST,
LET ME NOTE ON THE AXIOS POLL
IT, WE DON’T AGREE WITH HOW IT
WAS FREEZE.
IT SEEMS LIKE IT WAS TRYING TO
GET TO ANSWER RATHER THAN TRULY
ACCURATELY POLLING THE NATION.
I THINK PARENTS ACROSS THE
NATION UNDERSTAND THE SCIENCE,
THE DATA, AND THE NUMBERS, WHICH
IS THAT ONE FOR IF THE CASES ARE
IDENTIFIED IN SCHOOLS.
WE SEE A 62% DECREASE IN
REPORTING ON CHILD ABUSE HERE IN
D.C.
THEY KNOW THAT 70-80% OF KIDS
WITH MENTAL PROBLEMS GET THEIR
TREATMENT IN SCHOOLS, AND THEY
KNOW THAT, AS McKENZIE AND
COMODELED, THAT LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES ARE HURT THE MOST.
I HAVE SEVEN AND TEN LATINOS AND
SEVEN AND TEN BLACK AMERICANS
SAY THEY ARE WORRIED THEY DON’T
HAVE THE SKILLS WHERE THE
RESOURCES, I SHOULD SAY, AT HOME
TO PREP THE STUDENTS WERE CUTE
THEM UP TO PAR EDUCATIONALLY.
THAT IS A REAL FEAR MANY HAVE,
AND IT IS A CORRECT FEAR.
>> Harris: REAL QUICKLY, IS
THE PRESIDENT GOING TO RIP
FUNDING FOR SCHOOLS WHO FEEL
THEY ARE IN AREAS WHERE THE
CASES ARE SPIKING AND THEY CAN’T
REOPEN?
>> Secretary McEnany: THE
PRESIDENT IS ALWAYS ACKNOWLEDGE
THIS IS SOMETHING HE’LL TAKE A
LOOK AT, BECAUSE HE THINK THAT’S
PARAMOUNT FOR KIDS TO GO TO
SCHOOL.
BUT HE’S ALSO SAID HE WANTS THAT
FUNDING TO FOLLOW THE STUDENT.
IN FACT, I WILL NOTE FOR YOU
HERE, HARRIS, IN PHASE FOUR, WE
ARE FIGHTING FOR EXTRA FUNDING
FOR OUR STUDENTS.
WANT TO INCREASE IT BUT TARGET
IT AT THE STUDENTS.
>> Harris: PHASE FOUR.
IT WOULD BE GREAT IF CONGRESS
WOULD GET BACK TO WORK, RIGHT?
OH, I SAID THE QUIET PART OUT
LOUD.
>> Secretary McEnany: [LAUGHS]
>> Harris: HILLARY CLINTON
WITH THIS WARNING ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IF HE LOSES
REELECTION.
WATCH THIS AND I’LL GET YOUR
REACTION, KAYLEIGH.
>> I THINK IT IS A FAIR POINT TO
RAISE AS TO WHETHER OR NOT, IF
HE LOSES, HE IS GOING TO GO
QUIETLY OR NOT.
WE HAVE TO BE READY FOR THAT.
>> Harris: NOT JUST
HILLARY CLINTON, THOUGH.
JOE BIDEN ALSO RAISED THE SAME
POSSIBILITY LAST MONTH WHEN HE
SUGGESTED THE MILITARY MIGHT
HAVE TO ESCORT PRESIDENT TRUMP
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE.
WHEN I SAT DOWN WITH HIM, THE
PRESIDENT SAID, IF HE LOSES,
HE’LL DEAL WITH IT THE WAY
EVERYBODY ELSE DOES, BASICALLY.
PARAPHRASING HIM NOW.
WAS THE LATEST DIRECTION FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE ON THIS?
>> Secretary McEnany: IT’S
QUITE COMICAL TO WATCH THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY TALK ABOUT NOT
ACCEPTING THE RESULTS OF THE
ELECTION.
THE ONLY PEOPLE WHO HAVEN’T
ACCEPTED THE RESULTS OF
ELECTIONS OR PEOPLE IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, LIKE
HILLARY CLINTON, WHO BLAMES HER
LOSS ON SOMETHING LIKE TWO DOZEN
DIFFERENT ENTITIES.
NEVER BLAME YOURSELF.
STACEY ABRAMS ON A GEORGIA, WHO
STILL MAINTAIN SHE DIDN’T LOSE
THE ELECTION.
OF COURSE, SHE IS THE LOSING
FORMER DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE FOR
GOVERNOR.
SO, THE DEMOCRATS HAVE PROBLEMS
WITH THIS.
I THINK THIS IS THEIR WAY OF
ACKNOWLEDGING THEY HAVE SOME
REAL PROBLEMS IN NOVEMBER.
>> Harris: ALL RIGHT.